good morning believe nation today's
message is make your presence count over
the you trey songz there was quite lost
another new saw every week you know is
straight on his music monday i put out a
new song every monday for like two and a
half month before my mixtape came out
which was anticipation which got 50,000
downloads the first night you know
ready came out race had six or seven
singles i think that has a lot to do
with corner towards easy who's an
international superstar definitely
brings a lot of tension in my mini
perform with Stevie Wonder on BT on uh
you know I kiss Toni Braxton on stage
you know like so it was a lot of steps
towards where I am and I think that it's
just beginning even still you know
that's why I this run is so jam-packed
my schedule that's why I'm in a
different country everything because I
need to make my presence but and even
when I come back next time I'm out I'll
work even harder to make my presence
felt because I still I'm working here
this time like I'm gonna do act my
manager told me was gonna come on we
don't act like this 2005 what that means
is act like I just gotta make it you
know so I don't know Phil is doing a
superstar here yet I'm working my way
there so one of my personal goals is to
wherever I go that my presence is felt I
want to make sure that the thing that
I'm spending my time on has an impact
I'm heavily driven by impact and it's
not from a legal point of view not that
when I walk into a room you need to
worship me that's not the goal but
wherever I'm spending my time that
things are going to get better that if
I'm spending my time in this business
this business is going to get better
it's going to help the communities I'm
spending time making videos for you that
you are digesting them and using them
and helping them make you get better and
build awesome businesses that impact our
culture it's the goal if I felt like
these videos or not have
an impact on you then I would stop
making them I would still consume them
for myself there's a number of habits
that I picked up that it wasn't having
an impact on you guys but has an impact
on me so I just keep doing it for myself
I look at the morning gratitude series
as an example I had a youtube series
where every day I went on and shared
three things I was big before and
encouraged you guys to come on and do it
with me and we had a good loyal audience
coming and doing it but it wasn't having
the impact that I wanted and so I cut
the series I still do a person myself
every morning with my wife but I don't
share it with you guys because I want to
make sure that the things that I'm
spending my time on it's worthwhile I
think everybody should have the opinion
that wherever you walk into whatever
room you're in whatever business you're
in you're gonna make it better it's your
goal to make it better
again not from an eagle point of view
that I'm amazing and I'm going to do
this but from a genuine desire to make
things better to help people to elevate
to lift like if you are not making
things better you're either making
things worse which isn't great or you're
just a pathetic and is that the life
that you want to live do you want to
walk around going into all these rooms
and the rooms are your life your
business your friends you know these
different rooms of your daily existence
and just be apathetic and not really
caring what happened or if you go in
with the intention of my time matters my
life here is limited I want to make
every second count it shifts your
perspective and I think it's really
important one of the things I do in a
fairly consistent basis is look at my
schedule I look at where am i spending
my time I live and die by my calendar
where am i spending my time it's the
most precious asset that I have I'm
never getting it back where am i
spending it and doing a constant audit
of our deeds right places
should I still be making youtube videos
should I invest that time to go off and
do something else or not and the things
that always tipped the balance for me
is are these things leading to a major
impact or not my goal is to help a
billion entrepreneurs whether I reach
that goal or not it doesn't matter it's
the process it's the work that I'm doing
has to have the potential to help a
billion entrepreneurs if it does I'm
into it if it's not I'm not going to do
it and encourage you to value more time
more preciously and to do a severe audit
to look at where you are spending your
time and are you having a positive
impact on your customers on your
suppliers on your friend on your
relationships and everybody around make
your time camp
so the question date today is I'm
curious what are you spending time on
that you probably shouldn't that's not
really having an impact that you're not
making a presence felt
where are you wasting your time that you
want to change in your life of your
business leave in the comments below
I'm super curious if I know I also want
to give a quick shout out to it be hadid
thank you so much baby for picking up a
copy of my book your one word it really
really really means a lot to me and I
really hope you're enjoying the read so
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love and I'll see you
guys again tomorrow morning for another
shot of espresso
[Music]
I always tell people to do the biggest
biggest benefits of my career was
probably in the beginning the thing I
hated most like how long it took me to
get to a still while I was getting my
gesture yes you know my first out okay
of course the career was going crazy
just gotta make it gotta go like Wonder
Woman everything and odd nucleus on the
East Coast week but I wasn't as
successful as I want to speak was very
long time but the older I get the more I
appreciate that process that learning
curves the ability to grow gradually so
I had to learn everything in front of
everybody
I gotta get catapult immediately into
success that gave me appreciation for
the journey to get to success that gave
me appreciation that made me work hard
like that's why I work as hard as I do
now today cuz I feel like if got to make
it would win number one billboard chart
type of success my first thing ever I
don't think I had the same its behind I
love to do musics off always wrapped in
our always and you know the funny thing
about was when I was wrapping this thing
is like it was a summer out of this
world where he's going to sing and rap
but he's on be sing like Anna Beauty I
love about music nowadays that you have
artists that almost everybody do both
right you know what I mean so I think
that's a great part of evolution of
music is uh artists being creative and
believing in themselves no matter what
box that people try to put them in
because no matter what you're trying to
do with your life other people don't try
to put you in this box definitely but
you got to push through it just look
you know cause cause cause that's cause
you know that that's another intriguing
thing about their song that when I say I
suppose it's kind of like thinking in
hindsight that really what success is
no it's not special success is disease
being what we were taught that is the TV
community school videos etc but success
is really what makes you happy in your
heart making music makes me happy
[Music]